voilà certaines images que vous aviez
tourné Cyril payant notamment au Mali à
Bamako il y a pas eu de réaction
officielle euh de cette tentative de
coup d'état armé de la part des des pays
africains en tout cas peu est-ce que le
doute voir l'inquiétude s'installe dans
certains pays écoutez c'est un sujet un
peu compliqué qui a animé et qui a
focalisé la communauté internationale
tout le week-end et on peut penser
évidemment quand il y a un séisme d'une
telle importance une éruption politique
et militaire dans un pays aussi
important que la que la Russie il y a la
tectonique il y a toute la sphère
d'influence qui va qui va suivre et là
on l'espèce la sphère d'influence elle
est représentée par le corps
expéditionnaire je dirais de
l'expansionnisme russe c'est Wagner
c'est gagné Prigogine et alors
évidemment il y a l'Afrique mais il y a
aussi il y a le Soudan on en a très très
très bien rappelé dans ce sujet mais il
y a la Syrie le Proche-Orient et une
quantité de pays qui sont éligibles à
faire partie de cette sphère alors on
peut gager qu'effectivement dans les
pays qui ont été nommés Bangui notamment
la République centrafricaine qui est une
forme de de laboratoire de cette de ce
coup de force euh de de Wagner en
Afrique sahélienne en Centrafrique très
proche de l'extrême très proche du
pouvoir qui offre sécurité c'est le
logiciel Wagner sécurité et qui est
parfaitement illustré à Bangui donc
sécurité et puis des développements
d'une propagande en général
antioxydantal et plus particulièrement
en France anti-française contre
prédation des ressources naturelles ça
marche comme ça ça tendre d'ailleurs à
autonomiser un peu Wagner notamment en
Libye mais on pourra y revenir mais on
peut gager donc à Bangui qu'à Bamako
tous ces pays avec des gouvernements on
va le dire poliment qui se qui s'appelle
les gouvernements de transition mais qui
sont en fait des des gouvernements
putschistes je pense aussi d'une
certaine manière au Burkina Faso qui est
un peu plus profil basse ou cette
affaire en tout cas qui qui dément et
bien on peut se demander quel est
l'avenir puisqu'en fait on allait dans
l'aventure de l'expansionnisme russe
avec en fait un homme fort un socle d'un
grand pays qui se permet même de faire
la à son voisin et puis qui offre la
sécurité qui n'est pas regardons sur les
droits l'homme droit de l'homme bref une
sorte de nouveau contrat un nouveau
paradigme dans les relations
internationales face à au vieux système
notamment et bien les anciennes
influences comme la France qui est
demandé peut-être de faire un peu plus
d'efforts sur les droits de l'homme donc
tout allait bien dans le meilleur des
mondes dans ce nouveau logiciel des
relations internationales qui incluent
d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière le
logiciel chinois mais aussi le Turc
l'Iranien évidemment mais tout ça a été
basé sur la la théorie de l'homme fort
et là on voit bien et il est encore
évidemment extrêmement tôt pour se
lancer dans les conjonctures on ne sait
pas quels seront les vrais conséquences
sur le terrain en Russie de cette
mutinerie de ce coup d'État raté de
cette avancée de cette aventure
militaire de de prix gaugine sur Moscou
mais c'est vrai que on le disait
précédemment ça affaiblit l'un et
l'autre et Poutine n'apparaît pas
nécessairement aujourd'hui enfin on peut
le penser et c'est certainement comme ça
que c'est interprété dans ses capitales
dans cette sphère d'influence de de
Wagner cette interpréter comme un effet
glissement et en tout cas on est
peut-être un peu moins sûr et bien de
cette de cette fuite en avant qui est
appuyée par par le système de Moscou et
on l'espèce par le système Wagner
puisque le encore une fois le corps
expéditionnaire de toute cette
théorisation de ces 7 de cette
expansionnisme cette fin d'influence
ruse c'est vraiment prisé et on l'a vu
depuis quelques années depuis 2021 en
République centrafricaine l'arrivée à
Bamako avec des parties pris résolus et
sans appel c'est à dire que dès que les
Russes sont arrivés en développant un
très très habile il faut dire cette
fameuse guerre informationnelle en fait
de changer le narratif et avec très peu
de frais de lancer des infox de
totalement
déconstituer ce qui avait pu être
fabriqué dans les relations avec les
autres les pays traditionnellement
alliés je pense à la France notamment
pour la pour le sel pour le Sahel et
bien il y a eu un choix très très clair
avec l'édiction d'ambassadeurs le départ
de force de l'ONU en fait un message
extrêmement dit souveniste ou pas
d'africanisme et qui en fait un message
antioxydantal donc tout cela c'est porté
par le Kremlin et d'une certaine manière
ça se fragilise et on peut effectivement
se poser des questions donc se défaire
et se défaire des miliciens se défaire
de Wagner ça ça va être une équation
très compliquée pour pour ces régimes là
on en est pas encore là bien sûr bah
avec ce système de de prédation
prédation veut dire que on se paye sur
la bête si je peux dire sur des systèmes
de de financement minier toute forme de
ressources de toute façon on le voit en
Centrafrique ou c'est que comme ça que
que ça que ça se passe et que c'est
totalement acté ou en Libye où je le
rappelais qu'il y avait une forme
d'autonomisation on ne sait pas trop
comment on peut défaire même s'il y
avait un ordre du Kremlin la main mise
et les prérogatives des hommes du groupe
Wagner qui sont très très nombreux la
vraie question c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
que des conjectures alors est-ce que
rien ne change et qu'en fait on continue
puisque finalement Prigogine a négocié
dans sa fuite je rappelle qu'on a aucune
nouvelle de lui c'est un homme invisible
alors qu'il était sur sa chaîne
télégramme presque en permanence depuis
des semaines voire des mois notamment au
front à Dark Maud mai il y a rien ne
change on laisse Wagner continuer son
expansionnisme au nom du Kremlin avec
pregojim à sa tête très très difficile
en l'état à penser que c'est une une
option une possibilité deuxième chose
c'est il y a autour de Wagner énormément
de SMP c'est société militaires privées
qui sont des bébés Wagner énormément de
grandes sociétés russes ont été mis à
contribution par la lumière Poutine pour
créer des alias qui sont qui ne sont qui
ont pas la renommée ni la puissance de
Wagner mais qui pourrait pourquoi pas
prendre le relais ou alors et bien une
autre option potentiellement encore une
fois ce ne sont que des hypothèses qui
n'engagent que moi cette campagne de
pouvoir c'est qu'on garde Wagner en
l'état mais on change la tête c'est là
aussi qu'on va voir aussi le reste
d'influence d'afghani pregojin dans la
Russie d'aujourd'hui et dans cette
sphère d'influence ruse d'aujourd'hui un
mot sur le constat aujourd'hui par
exemple au Mali Wagner c'est implanté
officiellement pour faire reculer les
djihadistes on en est où
il y a deux discours si on est on écoute
les manifestants à Bamako et Bamako
n'est pas le reste du de ce grand pays
malien et bien tout va bien il y a des
progressions tous les jours de l'armée
malienne avec leur frère dame russe qui
est totalement donc le contraire de
l'engagement français qui a duré près de
10 ans qui est en l'espèce la
l'opération cervelle puis barquette donc
on défait ce qui a pu être fabriqué mais
les experts sur le terrain
sont assez assez clairs c'est pas parce
qu'on on retire des forces Ali
occidentales qu'on demande notamment à
la municipale à force de l'ONU l'une des
plus grands plus gros déploiement en
usien du du maïs qui est à l'ordre du
jour ça a été demandé la semaine
dernière et ça sera certainement acté
assez vite par par l'ONU c'est une
situation désastreuse catastrophique sur
le plan sécurité qui remet peut-être
même à la genèse de l'intervention
in extremis française en 2012
c'est-à-dire que les djihadistes sont
aux portes de Bamako pour l'instant ils
ne font que des des coups de force mais
en clair il y a Bamako et le reste du
pays n'est pas nécessairement totalement
tenu et ça ce n'est pas uniquement
évidemment le paradigme malien puisque
la République centrafricaine on le sait
bien il y a Bangui et le reste du pays
avec une multitude de de bonnes armées
donc c'est un une influence sur ce qui
s'est passé juste ces quelques heures
qui va être certainement quoi qu'il
arrive extrêmement importante dans ces
endroits où Moscou avait des visées très
très concrètes et précise merci pour ces
éléments de compréhension Cyril